[Music]
so I think by now I don't need to
convince anyone that moving to the cloud
is useful and important and I think a
challenge that many many enterprises
face today is how to do it and usually
we have like this huge infrastructure
and servers and thousands of different
applications and in order to understand
how to move them we need to identify
what do you want to move first what is
going to be the most useful what is
going to minimize our disruption to our
current application and most importantly
how can we move there as fast as
possible
so in general we talk about three
different steps in migration one is
assessment understanding what are the
difficulties that we are going to face
when we are going to migrate what is the
expected downtime
what should we communicate our users
then we do the actual migration after we
finish migrating with we tune our
applications to fit better to the cloud
of it better to the profile that we are
now running on GCP so usually what we in
the first step we even decide what after
we need to move and what ups can we even
move because sometimes not everything
can be just lifted and shifted and we
are going to talk about this in a minute
but what dependencies do we have is
everything going to be shifted as is or
are we going to modernize something what
are the Kate what are what is important
for application do we have some specific
performance requirements that might not
be met when we're in the cloud do we
have some specific latency requirements
and then essentially that step will tell
us what is the right path to the cloud
and we have I think in terms of tooling
this is probably the part that is the
most difficult today this is the part
where there is the least amount of
tooling we are going to show one partner
that have built an assessment tool for
migrating a specific type of
applications but I think that in general
this is the
place where we rely on knowledge and we
rely on the on either the engineer is
inside the company or on our own PS
organization to understand what the
impact is going to be for migration and
in general we have different migration
types and we need to understand how
exactly we are going to migrate I think
probably the best way to migrate is the
first one to retire the application I
mean if we don't need it anymore let's
just shut it down and that's it
migration is done unfortunately most
application we don't follow this pattern
and we actually need to be more complex
I guess if we can also replace it with
some new vendor or something already in
the clouds and start render that's also
pretty easy we first move to that vendor
and then we retire but then when we
actually need to move it then we have a
lot of options I guess the less this the
least disruptive option but also usually
the least useful is just to rehearse it
we take our servers as is and we migrate
those servers into the cloud about six
months ago Google acquired the Vella
strata which is a company does via
migration and there are other Google
partners that does that as well then we
start getting into the realm of actually
changing something in the application
when moving to the cloud and again this
is usually more destructive but also
more useful so we have we can revise our
application so maybe just move the VMs
but also maybe containerize some of them
to be able to run them on some container
engine so just a little bit a little bit
of change or we can actually factor so
change your application to different
modules some modules actually move to
new stuff let's say we take our database
which we are going to talk about in
Lang's in this talk and move it to
called sequel and then we take the other
part of our application and just move
the VMS and then we're going to the you
know things that usually are harder to
do which is complete rebuild or complete
rewrite of the application to fit a
cloud I think where we are going to
factor
to focus in this talk is on the refactor
area where we want to take some of our
footprint and move it into cloud native
tools mostly the databases and then some
of our front print we'll probably just
keep as is and we'll just talk to the
same in the same API the same way but
two new database degrees in the cloud
and then once we're done of course we're
going to optimize we're going to try to
optimize for cost going to optimize for
speed going to optimize for latency
that's only once we're done moving and
with GCP we can actually we we have
built and spent a lot of time and effort
in order to build migrations better and
one is of course the fundamentally
making the cloud itself better making it
scale the network performance and the
ability actually transfer data at great
speed the surface level on the SLO z--
of GCP and then the migration
capabilities itself which are migration
features migration tools and migration
partners and eventually you're not alone
in this we have a very good PS
organization and support that will help
you throughout the process and then i
mentioned usually during the assessment
phase and the pre-migration step is
where the organization is currently most
important compared to the tooling that
exists today but of course it's also
very useful in the migration itself and
then in the tuning because those are
people that actually know what's best
and what best tool to use and how to use
them in the cloud so let's talk about
different migration types one thing that
actually works very well today in google
cloud is we have the cloud compatible of
the on-premise stuff for cloud sequel
works both for my sequel and Postgres we
have memory store for ids which is a api
compatible to Redis and BigTable and
HBase are also API compatible so if
those are the dependencies of your
application
refactoring should be pretty easy as you
will not need to change any API
you will not need to change any drivers
in your application to just work as is
exactly the same way it works against
the on-premise databases so usually a
very common migration paths and the one
that we are going to extensively cover
in this session is to move the databases
themselves to the - called sequel or to
memory store and then move the
application using probably VM migration
and then you don't need to change
anything in the in the application
itself or in the drivers and then I
would say maybe the more interesting but
also not as easy migration path is when
we want to modernize database and this
happens usually for one of maybe two
reason one reason is we need more scale
we need better or my sequel instance can
no longer fit the bill what we need are
our Postgres instance is no longer
scalable enough for our data needs and
that's why we've built spanner and
spanner is a low latency very high
availability and scalable database
system in the cloud and it's not API
compatible my sequel not API compatible
with Postgres but very very similar so
usually most of the things that you're
able to do with my sequel and Postgres
both of your queries will just shift as
is there will be some work on making
understanding what's not exactly
compatible and then moving that the
other reason is I have tools that are I
would say I'm using them for many years
now and I want to modernize them so I'm
using Oracle for example I'm using
Cassandra and I want to move either to
called sequel to cloud a big table
usually the main reason we see moving
oracle to Postgres in the cloud is to
reduce costs and and then if we the
Cassandra migration that we see is just
sometimes at a certain size it is
becoming very difficult to manage your
own Cassandra cluster to understand the
issues the production issues are
happening and then moving to big day
usually takes away a lot of this load we
do have for this again the tooling here
are not as advanced but we did that we
do have a lot of guidelines a lot of
experience out of migration guidelines
it will help you do this and take you
step-by-step throughout that process of
doing the heterogeneous database
migration so as some of you may have
heard the Loom acquired google cloud
this actually have become official last
week Illuma has been focused on data
migration from the beginning five years
ago and inside Google myself and the
entire Illuma team is going to be
focused on delivering a great database
migration experience and then expanding
the current capabilities of database
migrations and the other side is we
don't think that we can provide
everything ourselves and we don't think
that you can do everything ourselves and
it was weak that's why we've partnered
with great companies like stream and the
other tools that I'm gonna show today is
a meek visor by nya Tech which helps
with that process as well so with the
partner ecosystem and took the in-house
tooling that we've built and your own
your own engineers the goal is to make
that migration as easy as possible we
have some customer examples so one
example is evernote evernote have moved
over from five billion user note into
GCP in two months a little bit over two
months Pantheon migrated 200,000 website
which they host from on trend to my
sequel just moving the my sequel
instance from 120 TP in couple weeks and
then Optive I moved from Oracle to
spanner
so about 10x increase in database
performance so those doing those
migrations are actually useful and
usually you know you probably ask
yourself why would I enter that
migration that painful migration project
it might take me a long time I take me
along therefore it usually it's worse it
usually sometimes it's not as painful as
you think it's going to be sometimes
existing tools can actually make it
easier and you can get it done in two
weeks or in a month and sometimes just
the performance impact the cost impact
is so great that is just worth it again
as well so with that let's try and focus
a little bit on migration into cloud
sequel and how to lift and shift your
application
hopefully with minimal downtime and
minimal effort in general the
recommendation is of course whenever
possible try and take the simple
approach and the simple approach is just
a downtime migration so I have let's say
I'm doing it like - like how much in
this migration I have in my sequel
instance on Prem I want to move it to
the same means as in the cloud usually I
would tell my users hey there's going to
be a downtime that downtime of course
depends on a database size stop writing
to the source database perform a dump
like in my she will dump or whatever to
move the schema and the data itself and
in the my sequel dump itself we could
also move triggers we can move anything
if we need spin up a new instance in the
cloud load the data to the instance in
the cloud switch DNS or the direction to
that server and that's it we're done
we re enable rights we're enable all of
the clients throughout your database and
that's very simple unfortunately it's
not always possible to take down time
it's not always and that can be from one
of two reason one reason can be the
database is just too big so the downtime
will be too will be too will be too long
the other is that it's business critical
application we won't be able to take
downtime one way again is to try and
make some optimization to reduce the
downtime and actually we have a lot of
trends with it we have a lot of like
these are some real-life great tips to
reduce the downtime when doing the
migrations some one is when importing
the data disable all foreign key is all
secondary keys because that
the database will not validate against
them so there is no need to actually do
that validation because you already know
you're moving the entire data set and
then when you import data also import it
and dump it of course in the order of
the primary key that you really makes
import that can have very very
significant impact on the import time in
terms of what are we choosing to import
into we want to make sure that I mean if
we can have the available Graham larger
than the data set it means that the
import time will be much faster using SD
storage or high i/o ops also greatly
reduces down time increases migration
performance and then during the import
process itself of course we're looking
at how fast the storage grows how fast
is what happened do we have any real
operation do we have paging that
happening and understand why import is
taking some time and also how to reduce
it so these are this is all fine these
are great and great tips but still not
good enough often times like often times
still we cannot take the downtime or
your nine-time will still be too long
and usually what you know if you have a
one terabyte or several terabytes my
single instance you just cannot take the
downtime or if you have a business
critical application it keeps writing
you need to keep writing you cannot take
downtime as well I'll go back to what we
can do after import but we have a that's
why we have an option of minimizing the
downtime when migrating so this is
essentially zero downtime and this is
already available for my sequel to my
simple migration in your GCP instance I
mean you can just click I'm not sure if
you ever seen this button that says
migrate data but this will actually do
the migration with very low downtime or
a zero downtime and the way it's done is
it will we have the art we have our
application it's still reading against
the existing database what that process
is doing is that process star
new instance start replication so like
bin log replication running between your
source on tram and the database in the
cloud as if it was another of the slaves
of their it as if it was a database
slave at some point the data between the
source and the target matches and then
we can pause right and then we can
really have minimal downtime maybe for a
minute or for a few minutes pause writes
to the existing instance move it to the
new instance and then resume and because
we had replication running the data will
be exactly the same so we can actually
move with minimal downtime and from our
experience what we've seen is that
minimal downtime migration are sometimes
the make or break off will I ever
migrate my application to the cloud will
I ever migrate my database to the cloud
so for them is equal to my sequel use
case that option is already available
we'll go in there we'll show it real
quick so let's say I have a data source
I'm pointing myself to the IP address
username password of the source database
I'm choosing the instance type of what
I'm going to migrate and again best to
choose according to the tape that we've
shown earlier and I'm pointing it to a
dump file so I ran my sequel dump at
some point in the near past I'm pointing
and I put it in in GCS I'm pointing it
I'm pointing it to a dump file I'm
creating a replica and after a few
minutes that replica will be created and
we'll have it on IP and once the replica
is created we can actually start their
application all you need to do in your
source database is give permission once
you've given permission to the database
to connect a slave you'll see the
replica starts creating so in that case
it's a read replica that's being created
and you can start monitoring the CPU the
utilization the storage and you can
actually see this
a fast torrid it was a very big database
took about 30 minutes to migrate this is
a fast-forward for two minutes but you
see the storage climbing up and and then
the latency is being measured the
latency essentially tells you what's the
difference between my current replica
and the original server in terms of how
far am i behind so at the beginning
you'll see it growing growing growing
growing and at that point it was 30
minutes at some point that replication
is done and we are catching up on the
bin log catching up on the bed log once
we've read all of the bin logs from the
source we would actually see the latency
going down to zero at that point you can
click you know what what you've seen
there which was promote replica once we
promote replica we stop right to the
source database we are not writing
anymore we click promote replica as
you've seen that process takes about 30
seconds which means it's no longer
applique ting it's now the primary
server and wanted the primary server and
it is promoted we can actually we can
actually start the rights from the
application directly to that replica and
that's it we're done we had a minimal
downtime migration between my sink or my
sleep or we can go back to the deck
yeah Oh
great so after after the import itself
I'm backing up a little bit here
essentially once we imported once our
application starts writing we start to
tune it we are monitoring the
performance we see do we have too many
rights we have too many weeds once the
application actually running we can
indeed Excel to improve the performance
we can maybe change the instance type if
we need more CPU or if we need more
memory we can turn on binary Laden if
you want to create our own replica now
we can we're again have a mine sequences
in the cloud we can have a replica we
can have a reed replica catsteros binary
logging on our cloud sequel instance and
essentially we're ready to go we have
our application running against database
in the cloud at this point we can keep
running our application VMs on tram we
can take the application VMs in migrate
them into the cloud as well to have a
full the entire application in the cloud
so this was for homogeneous my sequel to
my sequel migration that's great what
happens if we want to make to do a more
complex migration let's say we want to
migrate Postgres Oracle to Postgres so
we have a big Oracle instance on Prem
and we want to modernize our application
want to move to Postgres in the cloud so
here actually assessment is very
important and this this tool is a tool
by Anaya Tech called Mike visor and it
provides you with information how
difficult will it be to migrate your
Oracle instance into Postgres so you
choose a source you to the target in
that case I've chosen Oracle to Postgres
and I have here five or six databases
now what's nice about this tool all it
does is it will create the Oracle
metadata it will just run a bunch of
like a couple thousand queries on the
Oracle metadata I understand the current
usage understand are using a very
specific Oracle synonyms for example
that doesn't exist on cloud sequel what
do we need to do about it
are you using PL sequel extensively and
then you would need to convert that PL
sequel eventually each one of your
databases will get a grade
or of how complex will be to migrate
that database which is that bar chart
that you can see here so the ones with
the higher score are more complex
migration the ones with the lower score
should be like to just migrate very
easily because you're not using any
specific or proprietary Oracle stuff and
you can actually even see why so I guess
resolution here is not good enough but
you can actually dive deeper and say hey
this is very complex why is it so
complex and then you will see these are
the features the specific feature that
are being used by the which are not
compatible with Postgres or will will be
we need some manual introversion in
order to move to Postgres and you can
even see which users are using this
feature so you can say hey my CRM app
maybe I'm gonna keep it an Oracle for
now because it's using some very custom
stuff that I cannot move but my billing
up I might be able to move to to post
this and then the last thing that it
will do it will also analyze if the
Oracle usage is more of analytics or
OLAP a usage type or is it all TP
transactional type and if it's a
analytics usage type you might be better
served with migrating that specific
application that specific usage into
bigquery and not into Postgres so it
will tell you hey this type of
application is using mostly all of
queries consider not moving to Postgres
but moving into a data warehouse that's
designs for analytics like bigquery and
those applications are doing mostly OLTP
or mostly transactional you load and
then it's better to go to Postgres so
currently my attack amygdala supports
assessment of migrations from Oracle to
cloud sequel Postgres in my sequel and
coming soon by them is also migrations
into spanner and with that I want to
call on coding in a lock to show us a
demo of the actual migration with stream
so we finished the assessment we decided
that
we want to do the migration we want to
move over Oracle to Postgres one way of
doing it is to your stream so thank you
very welcome everybody my name is Alec
and I'm from stream I sort of feel like
then the brain surgeon after the
complexity has been 100 so I get into
the picture and tell you how to do the
the heterogeneous migration from Oracle
to post stress that's my demo today what
I'm going to do is just click to the
next okay just want to make sure my
clicker is working here let's go to the
next slide pronin sorry all right just a
little bit before I get into the demo so
stream is the next generation platform
and we focus on three different solution
categories the categories are cloud
adoption hybrid cloud data integration
and in-memory stream processing for the
focus today is on cloud adoption and I'm
delighted to announce a partnership with
Google on cloud adoption especially in
the area of database migration so what
I'm going to focus today is on the
Oracle 2 cloud sequel post rest
migration and especially as Yair pointed
out that downtime is a big problem
especially for mission-critical
applications so you might have a number
of different applications from your CRM
billing payments for banking etc and
these might not necessarily be able to
take any kind of an outrage but you
still want to actually move on to your
initiatives for you know cloud
modernization or for continuous
operations you might also have data on
other clouds and you wanted to
synchronize that with newer applications
that you're deploying on the on the
Google cloud so those are all the
benefits that you gain of course the
critical problem here is the the the
downtime part so let's get into the demo
and I'm gonna actually show you how
stream helps you do that so this I'm
gonna just have Corinne helped me with
the demo and this is the laning phase
each of the stream product there are
three parts here there's a dashboard
space there's the apps apps of the
pipeline so you'll hear me
interchangeably use apps and data
pipelines and then there's also you can
actually preview your sources before you
get started so we're gonna jump into the
apps part of the of the demo what you
see here are pre-built pipelines and
remember this is a zero downtime type of
scenario I'm talking about this has two
critical phases there's phase one which
is instantiation but that's where you
make a one-time copy of all of the data
which could be gigabytes perhaps
terabytes or it could be lesser and then
followed by a catch-up or
synchronization phase which we achieved
through some very specialized readers
that help you catch up the source and
the target and ultimately the two sides
are going to be in sync so let's step
into the initialization phase well so
this is a simple a pipeline that shows a
pipeline going from an on-premise Oracle
database into a cloud sequel post rest
database the way this was built was
using a flow designer by choosing a
number of out-of-the-box components
where you configure your your sources
for example in your targets and you can
also transform the data along the way
because it may be interesting because
the data formats might be different or
you may want to realign some of the data
as you're going through let's step into
the configuration of just the Oracle
database so here's where you configure
all of the different properties and it's
pretty you know flexible in terms of how
you want to move the data on the cloud
side here's where you provide your
service account your connections into
the post as sequel database in this case
we are going to be actually moving two
separate tables for the purposes of the
demo we're going to attempt to do a live
migration of a million records of the
line items table as well as do some DML
activity in phase 2 with the change in
our capture for the orders table so
let's go ahead and deploy the
application and this can the stream can
run in the cloud or on on-prem it's up
to you it's pretty flexible and as we
deploy it you cannot see that there's a
does this is a deliberate mismatch that
we introduced you heard yeah you talked
about some of the assessment checks and
so forth so it's important before you
actually do the migration that the
source is in the tea and the target
schemas etc sort of add up they're
compatible there's no exceptions etc so
here it did detect that there's one
incompatible datatype so we'll go ahead
and just skip this specific one we have
a coroner's actually fixed this in
another flow so we're gonna jump into
that initial load flow so let's go ahead
and deploy that and once we deploy it
it's ready to get started
we want to check for in whether the
tables are already empty so in this case
in the line item table you can see that
the count is zero and now we're going to
go ahead and run the application that's
the one that actually goes to the to
your critical database which is Oracle
on Prem starts go ahead and you can run
that current start the application we'll
also preview the data along the way so
once the you can see now the data is
beginning to flow in in this case we
have a million records in the in the
line items table and that sort of keeps
going and you can also monitor the
application progress you can see that so
far we have four hundred thousand input
the output input obviously are changing
so this is where a lot of the magic is
happening so things like batch
optimization things like parallelism
things like event guarantees things like
commit semantics all of this stuff is
taking place behind the scenes so it
will be turns actually consistent when
you actually in a complete the migration
so now I think we're done why don't we
take a look at the posted sequel
database make sure that and there you go
so your million records table was just
just moved pretty quickly and so the
performance is very impressive with that
what I want to do is remember this could
be gigabytes or terabytes of data what
we want to do is during this time all of
the data that is actually changing in
the database so this this is your actual
activity that is is being moved using a
technique or change in a capture so
stream allows you to actually have a
specialized reader and in this case
let's step into that so here's where the
reader properties are in the interest of
time we can go a little faster same
configuration for the for the
obviously and in this case now what we
do is we take activity from the redo log
of the Oracle database and we are going
to effectively replay that on the target
side to catch them up thereby avoiding
any kind of an outreach to the
production database so again in this
case we have a mismatch here it's more
for precision mismatch in this case I'll
ignore it because I already know that
all my data values adhere to the target
side schema so go ahead and ignore that
and we want to actually go ahead and
move the table here again the preview
option is selected and let's go ahead
and start it Boden's going to generate
some vml activity using a separate
simulator this is where you're going to
see some inserts updates and deletes and
you can see that he's running a number
of DML operations against the orders
table and then stream you can actually
already see that now not only are we
capturing the data but also the metadata
so these are things from the Oracle
database like the transaction ID the
system commit number all of the metadata
as a table name the operation type
insert update delete you can filter on
stuff like this and then you can
actually go finally log into the orders
table and see that there's in fact data
present in this table this was empty
beforehand so this is sort of a combined
technique of instantiation followed by
change era capture and application that
allows you to at your own leisure move
your on-prem database into the cloud
database you can actually go ahead and
test both sides while the migration is
ongoing it may take you a day a week or
potentially months depending on the size
of the database but the key benefits are
that there's no outage and you can keep
your operations continuous for your
mission-critical applications
[Music]